[Musique]
et quelques temps je suis tombé sur
cette vidéo
[Musique]
alors c'est une vidéo comme on en voit
souvent généralement sous titré d'un
retentissant voyez comme la compassion l
entraide sont des valeurs issues du
règne animal ses canards nourrissent les
poissons quelle beauté dans le geste qui
est la négation chasse aux oiseaux
mais voilà en réalité ces canards ne
nourrissent pas les poissons les canards
appartiennent au groupe des anatidés une
famille d'oiseaux qui ont la
particularité d'avoir un mec filtreurs
adapté à fouiller le fond des lacs et
des rivières à la recherche de
nourriture leur régime alimentaire est
principalement herbivores bien qu'une
certaine espèce ne rechigne pas à avaler
un peu de protéines supplémentaire vers
de vase micro crustacés ou encore albin
de poisson tout y passe et normalement
là vous devez commencer à voir au jeu
entre nous et je me demande tu vas aller
chercher les anatidés doit filtrer leur
nourriture pour la balle et ils ne
peuvent pas avaler de la nourriture
sèche parce que tout simplement ça
n'atteindra jamais le fond de leur
bouche sans l'aide d'un liquide pour le
porter c'est simplement un problème de
conformation du bec
donc quand vous donnez de la nourriture
sèche à un canard il va obligatoirement
la tremper dans l'eau et clapet son bec
plusieurs fois très rapidement pour que
si l'eau et la nourriture vers le fond
du bec et ainsi pouvoir la vallée c'est
aussi pourquoi quand on donne du pain
aux canards on a l'impression qui
barbotent un peu d'en haut avec leur bec
avant de manger un peu comme si jouer
avec la nourriture qui sait les canards
ok je pensais c'était juste un exemple
hockey ne donnait pas de pain aux
canards préféré le la salade ou des
petits pois va donc pour conclure dans
ces vidéos de canard soi-disant
nourrissant des poissons on voit surtout
que ses cours aux ados doivent disputer
leur pitance à des hordes de poiscaille
la famille qui d'ailleurs me fait
m'interroger sur la capacité de leurs
soigneurs animaliers à savoir prendre
soin de simples canard c'est un tantinet
inquiétant abete
dans tous les cas ces vidéos de canard
et de signes oies et autres anatidés
nous montre qu'on est bien mal placé
entente
humains pour comprendre ce qui se passe
réellement en face de nous on a tendance
à observer le monde avec nos yeux et
notre expérience du mal et donc à donner
ces comportements des connotations des
sentiments des justifications très
humain même site de base c'est
absolument pas le cas s'appelle
l'anthropomorphisme non c'est juste la
contraction de deux mots on propose web
en grec est mort fait don forme
donc en gros on échange en humain en
leur prêtant des comportements
typiquement m d'ailleurs ce n'est pas le
seul comportement qu'on a tendance à mal
comprendre que chez les canards dans
cette vidéo un homme essayé de séparer
des canards qui semble se battre alors
je ne sais pas ce que vous en pensez
mais de mon point de vue il apprend bien
compris ce qu'est en train de se
produire
ce canard pourchassé par les autres est
une semelle colvert voit son plumage
brun très différent de celui des mâles
qui ont fait de cadeaux divers brillant
extrêmement reconnaissable je ne suis je
pas les parloirs
merci des canards colverts à une parade
nuptiale des plus simples que voici
le mâle et la femelle se tourner deux
tours il auch un peu la tête la femelle
accepte le mal tout va bien
le problème c'est quand la femelle mais
pas consentante en l'occurrence pointe
elle a déjà des caps tout comme celles
présentées dans la vidéo précédente
lorsqu'elle refuse il arrive souvent que
des mâles frustré s'y mettent alors à
plusieurs et soumettre la femelle par la
force en la plaquant au sol voire sous
l'eau qui sont sur un lac et en essayant
de lui monter suis tous à la fois
alors ne me fait pas dire ce que je n'ai
pas dit le viol c'est mal et on est tous
d'accord avec ça mais ce que ce monsieur
n'a pas bien compris c'est que notre
conception de la chose en tant qu'humain
n'a rien à faire dans la tête d'un
canard pour eux c'est parfaitement
naturel et normal et en essayant de
faire fuir les assaillants qui n'a fait
que retarder l'inévitable car ça se
reproduira de toute manière qu'ils le
veuillent ou non une fois qu'il aura
tourné le dos sans compter il a aussi
distribué des coups de pied et
possiblement amoché les pétioles qui
n'ont certainement rien compris elle sa
colère soudaine essayé d'expliquer le
concept de viol un canard et on parlera
ensuite il aurait été plus utile de
garder ses poussins sous surveillance en
tant que ça se passe ça aurait évité que
les petits ne se fasse gobé par un autre
oiseau pendant qu'il s'est évertué à
courser les canards non parce qu'à cause
de lui ça a pris deux fois plus
longtemps il est mal n'ont même pas eu
ce qu'ils voulaient en conséquence la
femelle subira ce viol deux groupes une
deuxième fois laissant une fois de plus
ses canetons censuré ans et donc à la
merci des prédateurs
c'est ça comme on dit l'enfer est pavé
de bonnes intentions
ce que jean entrer ici c'est qu'en tant
qu'humain nous avons déjà du mal à
comprendre les comportements de chiens
domestiques des mammifères alors
imaginez essayer de comprendre un oiseau
bien plus éloigné nous c'est bien simple
nous ne sommes pas capables et pour ça
c'est quelque chose qui au caire la
plupart du temps un apprentissage et
encore même en ayant une bonne
compréhension l'espèce c'est pas
toujours évident voyons voir il ya le
picbois j'ai plus un groupe d'espèces en
réalité il s'agit de petits oiseaux qui
viennent manger les parasites sur le dos
des grands herbivores
[Musique]
voilà généralement ils sont cités comme
exemple de la coopération entre les
espèces dans le règne animal pas
exactement aux mots sont réseau
d'attraper les tic les mouches et autres
bestioles désagréable qui parasitent les
grands herbivores mais parfois il faut
un peu de zèle
lorsqu'un animal présente une plaie ce
que ce soit dieu est une piqûre ou un
coup ils ont une fâcheuse tendance à la
grandit en grignotant des bouts de peau
en attendant son c'est logique
cette plaie c'est un buffet à volonté
pour imagine les mouches attirées par le
som viennent pondre dans la plaie sa
faim montceau d'asticots bien juteux en
quelques jours
et puis ils peuvent eux-mêmes ne sont
pas contre une petite gorgée de sang
fait dans un autre bon vraiment disons
qu'ils en profitent c'est tout oui oui
ce seront l'appel du parasitisme
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
les véritable symbiose des relations
dans lesquels les deux espèces au
théâtre bénéfice équivalent sans que ce
soit aux dépens de d'entre elles c'est
extrêmement a sigh liste mais c'est loin
d'être la norme
on croise bien plus souvent des cas qui
tendent vers le parasitisme comme celui
des pilotes et autres noms noms quoi
vraiment de mon point de vue elle essaie
surtout de voir si ces mangeable pas
certaine qu'elle le pouce et surtout
l'impression qu'elle attaque l'arrière
train pour lui de faire sortir la tête
lorsqu'il est en boule et une fois la
tête sorti l attaque comme muzeau non
j'ai comme l'impression de set cornet
essayer de se payer une tranche des
sétoises hall d'une corneille manque les
membres de la grande famille des
corvidés qui contient notamment les
corbeaux et les choucas les corvidés
sont des hommes niveau on mange un peu
tout ce qu'ils trouvent
certains comme la can am anglais sont
plus spécialisés dans les charognes ou
la viande en général et il s'attaque
volontiers à d'autres petits animaux ici
celui là a visiblement décidé de se
faire une piste de cancun
ce sont des proies faciles ça se défend
pas ça a du mal à courir sans blague
donc pour en revenir à la corneille
manque les sept réseaux est un habitué
des charognes sur le bord des routes
car c'est malheureusement là qu'on
retrouve le plus de morts chez ils sont
notamment parce que le contenu voiture
arrive au lieu de tuer il se met en
boule de la route et hop faut savoir que
les corbeaux et autres corvidés sont des
oiseaux particulièrement intelligents
ils comprennent vite et savent résoudre
des puzzles qui sont bien au delà des
capacités intellectuelles de nombreux
animaux même appuyé par des primates
font pâle figure à côté
la corneille donc c'est très bien qu'un
hérisson sur la bord de la route c'est
généralement un repas faciles et on a
certainement vu des dizaines écrasé ou à
moitié mort il ya tout à faire un bon
gueuleton
le problème c'est que celui là est
encore bien vivant et elle ne peut pas
atteindre la viande à travers les petits
cambrai s'est elle essaie donc de
remédier au problème en les piquant les
fêtes pour faire sortir la tête et donc
avoir accès à la viande non protégés par
les douloureuses aiguilles pousser l'ue
à l'issue vers le bord de la route n'est
qu'un effet secondaire de ses actions à
but purement alimentaire cette vidéo a
reçu de nombreux gènes départager à gogo
des tas de commentaires sur les récents
de respect et d'humilité donné par la
nature et avec un grand m
non non c'est certain voir qu'on n'est
pas les seuls à penser au bien-être de
l'autre et se dire que ces valeurs de
respect se retrouve aussi en
interspécifique donc entre espèces c'est
très rassurant
et on voudrait y croire parce que c'est
un beau sentiment mais il faut bien
comprendre qu'à piquer notre
raisonnement du main aux autres espèces
est un peu comme essayer de faire
rentrer la mauvaise clé dans une serrure
même si ça rentre dans ton tape dessus
avec un marteau il ya de fortes chances
pour que la série soit en y est après
coup l'anthropomorphisme c'est pareil et
c'est essayer de comprendre le monde
avec notre raisonnement à nous et ça ça
ne fonctionne pas c'est pas la bonne clé
pour le décoder tout simplement les
autres espèces ni nos préoccupations et
notre mode de vie
[Musique]
ouais alors à ce propos j'espère que tu
te rends compte que ta crédibilité
avoisine le zéro parce que niveau
respect du temps rappelle tout de même
que tu serais tout mon appart et mon
frigo par la même occasion
[Musique]
la meilleure forme du respect que l'on a
pour la nature qui nous entoure serait
de laisser une espèce agir selon leurs
besoins sans intervenir
respecter la nature sait rester humble
et comprendre que chacune de nos actions
a une conséquence etc avant d'essayer de
vouloir faire correspondre les espèces
l'idéal purement rima il nous faut
réfléchir sur les raisons de ce qui se
produit devant nous de la même manière
que ce que nous faisons en conclut main
et totalement incompréhensible pour elle
ce que les autres espèces faux et très
nébuleux de notre point interprète un
d'après interprète aka prêtes ou en
hiver c'est ça et à moins d'avoir passé
des années à les observer faire des
recherches sur un mode de vie leurs
habitudes et n'est souvent pas possible
d'analyser leur comportement avec
justesse le monde qui nous entoure est
une source d'émerveillement perpétuelle
qui en ce qui me concerne tout du moins
ne sera sans doute jamais mais il est
déjà formidable tel quel nul n'est
besoin de lui imposer nos propres
limitations humaine si vous avez des
vidéos traitant d'oiseaux qui semble
avoir des comportements étranges
laissez-moi les liens dans les
commentaires et j'essaierai de voir si
je peux vous donner une explication
et si vous êtes plutôt du genre à
chercher par vous même il ya pléthore de
livres sur le sujet si ça vous intéresse
vous pouvez commencer par un cela
j'espère que cette vidéo aura su vous
faire réfléchir au moins un peu et je
vous dis à la prochaine pour de
nouvelles aventures avec les plus
[Musique]